bonjour énormément sokal émission qui
parle de livres qui parlent de sciences
humaines pour ce quatrième épisode on va
s'intéresser à monsieur sociologie en
france depuis les années 70 et les
nommer pierre bourdieu alors pour parler
de là mais pour parler de ces travaux on
va s'intéresser à un objet qu'il aimait
à détester à savoir la télévision
donc on va arrêter de taper cinq minutes
et on va s'intéresser au petit écran et
à ses grands problèmes
tiens bon dieu est né dans les pyrénées
atlantiques en 1930
après des études brillantes au collège
et au lycée il va intégrer normale
supérieure en 1951 à l'époque la normale
supérieure lorient c'était pas trop
lancer de crottes de même puisque ses
camarades est autre que jacques derrida
qui deviendra l'un des plus grands
penseurs et philosophes français etc
aura pas mal d'influencés également aux
états unis lucien blanco qui est sera
considéré comme le spécialiste de la
révolution maoïste en chine ainsi que
louis marin qui est un grand critique
d'art et qui est spécialisé dans
l'histoire des représentations donc il
va ensuite sortir maintenant elle
supérieure pour obtenir finalement sur
une agrégation de philosophie en 1954
puis il va commencer sa carrière
universitaire mais là il va y avoir une
grosse rupture puisqu'il va être envoyé
en algérie dans le cadre de son service
militaire
de 1958 à 1960 il durera huit d'or deux
fois plus longtemps que la guerre
mondiale elle fit tomber si président du
conseil et se font dès la quatrième
république
cette période représente pour lui une
grosse structure car elle finalement il
va pas lancer ses bouquins de philo et
il va s'intéresser uniquement à la
sociologie et avec nos logis de terrain
c'est dans ce cadre notamment qu'en 1958
il va écrire sociologie de l'algérie où
il va s'intéresser principalement aux
régions de kabylie et de colo qui sont à
ce moment là des régions qui sont
particulièrement prise par la guerre
civile qui a lieu alors en algérie puis
à la fin de son service militaire il va
rentrer en france en 1960 et il va à ce
moment-là s'appliquer à faire sauter un
petit peu tous les verrous et toutes les
notions classiques de l'ethnologie et de
la sociologie en france c'est bidon
c'est du pipeau donc dans ce monde de la
sociologie bourdieu se définit comme un
structuraliste constructiviste eux dont
vous ne savez pas ce qu'est un truc tu
réponds foothills brousse par là une
notion un petit peu simple donc bourdieu
se définit comme un structuraliste
constructiviste donc en fait en
structuraliste c'est quelqu'un qui croit
que les institutions et les règles de la
société vont conditionner ces agents un
constructiviste au contraire ce serait
plutôt quelqu'un qui pense que ce sont
les individus donc les agents avec leur
degré liberté à eux qui vont
conditionner la société et qui vont
engendrer de nouveaux agents cette
opposition théorique espèce se situer
avant tout ici donc bourdieu il était un
petit peu à la croisée de ces deux
penser à savoir qu'il est convaincu que
c'est l'alliance de l' influence des
individus sur les institutions et de
l'influencé d'institutions sur les
individus qui va construire le tissu
social sur dans lequel nous évoluons
tous
donc elles vont s'intéresser à l'objet
qui nous intéresse particulièrement
aujourd'hui à savoir la télévision on va
s'intéresser en premier lieu à trois
grandes notions qui sont présentement
majorité du travail de bourdieu à savoir
l'habitus les champs sociaux et la
violence symbolique
en premier lieu on va parler de
l'habitus donc l'habitus c'est
l'hypothèse selon laquelle les individus
au sein de la société ont des
dispositions à agir ce que tu as dit en
fait c'est qu'en grandissant et en
fonction du milieu dans lequel on évolue
on va avoir une certaine grammaire un
certain vocabulaire une certaine
propension à certaines activités et même
à certaines personnes en fait ce que dit
bourdieu c'est que ce sont des
structures dans lesquelles les individus
sont un petit peu enfermé au sein du
social et dont il va être très difficile
de s'extraire potentiellement en
grandissant au 22e avec de faibles
revenus et un faible capital culturel et
ben tu serais amené à avoir des
activités dites populaires alors que si
tu viens d'un milieu riche avec un
capital culturel avec un fort capital
culturel tu sera amené à avoir des goûts
et des activités un peu plus élitistes
ou voir bourgeoise mais au spectre et
cette vision du social elle est à nyon
dans un premier temps parce qu' il
existe des individus qui parviennent à
s'extraire de ces de ces prix contenu et
de ses prédispositions à agir et dans un
deuxième temps parce que c'était une
grille de lecture qui a été effectué
pour les années 70 et on sait que même
si des inégalités demeurent que ce soit
au niveau des pratiques ou des
prédispositions à agir dans les années
soixante dix sept titres
cette idée de classe était encore plus
présente et peut-être plus prégnante au
sein de la société est un milieu peu kyo
jo réfractaires à la lecture
l'agriculteur circuit et deux doubles
lignes sur trois n'a lui jamais de
livres alors que trois quarts des cadres
tels y aurait des professions libérales
en ligne
deuxièmement on à la notion de champ
donc pour bourdieu le social c'est une
imbrication de différents champs une
grande boîte de lego avec plein de
chance sociaux à l'intérieur donc ces
champs elles peuvent être religieux
politique culturelle est en fait les
individus vont se positionner dans ses
différents champs et en s y essayer du
coup d'en retirer des atouts alors par
exemple un individu il va être aller
dans une église qui avaient partie du
champ religieux ni va faire partie d'une
association sportive qui va faire partie
de ce champ là et qu'il va travailler
dans une usine dans un bureau il fera
partie également de ce champ là tous ces
éléments là en fait vont créer son
univers de chant et en fait il va
s'approprier les codes les valeurs et
les ressources de ses différents champs
parce que chaque chant finalement à ses
stratégies et ses règles enfin la
dernière motion que je voulais aborder
c'est la notion de violence symbolique
airwatch essaris trop cher et le nouveau
king côte belge est ce donc la violence
symbolique c'est le fait pour les
individus et donc les agents
d'intérioriser les normes et les
principes qui incombe directement à leur
position dans le social et donc à leurs
rapports de domination aussi parce que
ça dit c'est que finalement qu'on va
accepter et qu'on va prendre une
position dans le social les logiques de
domination qu'elle fois explicite ou
implicite
on va naturellement les accepter et
naturellement à les exercer sur l'autre
donc par exemple dans une entreprise
c'est assez naturel pour les câbles de
devenir avec par exemple une cravate ou
une chemise ou en costume de façon
générale par contre pour la personne qui
fait le ménage potentiellement elle a
plutôt arriver avec une blouse avec un
bleu ou avec un autre vêtement mais pas
avec un costume et si cette personne là
arriver un jour avec un costume
potentiellement c'est interpellera tout
le monde alors que sas dans cette
entreprise là il ya de grandes chances
que ça n'ait jamais été dit de façon
explicite est définie par tout le monde
c'est juste une forme de domination qui
ne dit pas vraiment ce qu'elle est mais
qui s'impose naturellement aux individus
une fois qu'ils prennent leurs positions
et c'est avant tout ça en fait la
violence symbolique
donc voilà pour ce qui est des grands
concepts de notre pire nationale est
donc désormais on va se concentrer sur
la télévision et plus particulièrement
peut-être sur l'information à la
télévision mais bonjour c'est un beau
week-end d'automne qui s'avance donc
pour dieu et c'est pas mal intéressé aux
journalistes et à la façon qu'ils ont de
construire l'information donc on va
s'intéresser justement à cette
information à la télévision et à la
façon dont cette information peut être
dangereuse ou en tout cas préjudiciable
au social et à sa construction la
première chose qu'il dit sur la
télévision c'est qu'elle a besoin du
spectaculaire
et pour cela elle a facilement aux cours
aux faits divers
en fait la télévision c'est quelque
chose qui est quotidien et pourtant qui
doit sortir justement du quotidien et
donc pour cela il utilise les faits
divers qui selon bourdieu font diversion
le petit jeu de mot de fait de par
l'utilisation je demande c'est fait
divers qui sont donc motivés par la
course à l'audience il est impossible
que des informations face diversion est
à la fois elles remplissent leur rôle
d'informer le citoyen sur la société et
de l'aider à faire son devoir de citoyen
au sein de cette même société
donc le fait que les journalistes soient
pressés par le temps et pressé également
par l'audimat amène une autre
problématique est la problématique de la
catégorisation parce que pour pouvoir
expliquer quelque chose de complexe il
faut prendre du temps il faut nuancer il
faut pondérer les différentes
informations pour essayer d'en rendre le
l'image la plus fidèle possible
et puisqu'on n'a pas le temps à la
télévision et qu'il faut justement du
spectaculaire et du direct eh bien on a
recours à une catégorisation c'est à
dire une mise en catégorie des individus
les acteurs du social et également leur
environnement donc cette catégorisation
c'est l'utilisation de pré conçue pour
pouvoir expliquer et pour pouvoir mettre
en images le social par exemple si vous
présente une image sur la banlieue est
bien très facilement il va y avoir un
noir un arabe avec des capuches et on va
parler de violence et communautarisme
c'est des sujets qui sont tellement
souvent abordés par la télévision qu' il
n'y a même pas besoin d'expliquer on
sait tout de suite de quoi ça parle
et comment la télévision va en parler et
donc du coup en ayant toujours recours
au même schéma et au même prix conçus
pour parler d'un sujet est bon on va
créer des catégories dans le réel et qui
dans la représentation et qui dans
l'imaginaire de beaucoup vont faire
partie intégrante du réel
même si c'est avant tout des catégories
de langage les catégories de discours
balp et c'est plus trop la france en
fait on est bouffé par les slaves
secteur cette catégorisation l amorce
une autre problématique qui est
justement cet effet de réel c'est à dire
que c'est un peu le syndrome de la
prophétie auto réalisatrice
c'est à dire que à force de présenter
des façons de concevoir la société à
force de présenter des prix conçus et
bien finalement les agents les individus
et la société elle-même va se conformer
à ces divisions la télévision et que les
formats télévisuels ou les formats de
l'information vont avoir sur elle
donc du coup ça ça amène un engouement
assez fort pour les politiques et pour
tous les individus qui veulent peser sur
les décisions et sur l'orientation que
va prendre la société d'être présent de
façon médiatique et donc de se conformer
à ces prix consulat et donc ça va créer
à nouveau nouvelle prédispositions et de
nouveaux préconçues et donc là tout cela
va se mettre en marche pour finalement
ne jamais sortir de ces catégorisations
là est enfermé encore plus les individus
dans des schémas de représentations déjà
établis bourdieu il cherche pas à les
pointer du doigt les journalistes c'est
juste de dire que la façon dont est
conçu l'information va créer un effet de
système et qu'avec le temps qui leur est
allouée était très faible la course à
l'audience les restrictions économiques
eh ben on vachon va produire une
information qui va être telle qu'elle va
produire tous ses effets néfastes au
sein du social donc bourdieu ce constat
elle le pose sur la télévision
cependant à l'heure d'internet et de la
surabondance d'informations on est en
droit de se demander finalement est-ce
que ce constat il a vraiment évolué à ce
sujet les chercheurs ton d'affirmer deux
choses en premier lieu oui
l'information s'est multiplié il ya
beaucoup plus de sources d'information
et potentiellement on peut tout dire de
l'extrême droite juste trail extrême
gauche de l'information ultra locale sur
le patelin à l'information
internationale tous potentiellement peut
être dit et tout peut-être sera dit mais
car il ya un mais disponible ne veut pas
dire visible et il faut dire qu'à ce
titre si toute l'information désormais
et potentiellement disponibles il faut
encore que celle ci puisse être mise en
visibilité ou publiciser et aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que c'est notamment les
anciens médias même sur internet qui
tiennent la dragée haute à tous les
autres et notamment on a le monde le
figaro tf1
tous ces médias sont présents et même
plus présent que les joues journaux qui
ont émergé que les nouvelles sources
d'information qui ont émergé avec
internet
dès lors on s'aperçoit que ce sont
toujours les mêmes voies qui sont les
plus audibles et il ya même de nouvelles
contraintes qui se sont rajoutés à ça
puisqu'on a notamment l'algorithme de
google qui est très important pour ces
médias l'art qui fait que l'information
doit être libre et d'une certaine façon
écrite une certaine façon pour qu' elle
soit visible et qu'elle soit mise en
visibilité notamment par l'algorithme de
google
toutes ces contraintes la faune que oui
il y a beaucoup plus d'informations pour
autant les canons de visibilité et les
informations qui sont présents et
disponibles à nous en tant que lecteur
et le public sont plus ou moins toujours
les mêmes sources d'information bref
c'est tout un tas de conditions qui font
que l'information est calibré d'une
certaine façon et tend vers le
spectaculaire et encore une fois non pas
à part
une grande corporation qui voudraient
peser de son poids sur la société
proviennent d'un ennemi unique qui leur
faut combattre et n'imagine pas que ceux
ci sont le fruit d'un ter relation hyper
complexe que personne ne contrôle est
triste mais plutôt par différentes
contraintes qui vont conditionner
l'information telle qu'elle est faite
est telle qu'elle est prodiguée par les
médias et par internet
aujourd'hui cependant pas de défaitisme
face à cette situation puisque comme on
l'a dit précédemment internet justement
laisse le choix donc après il nous
appartient qu à nous en tant que lecteur
en tant qu'auditeur d'essayer de faire
le choix entre les différentes sources
d'information d'essayer de prendre de
plusieurs sources d'information
disponibles afin de se faire son propre
avis critique sans jamais tomber dans un
complotisme sans jamais tomber dans un
radicalisme mais juste essayé de
pondérer les différentes informations
pour se créer sa propre idée et sa
propre opinion en tant que citoyen avant
de vous quitter je vais vous conseiller
la vidéo de bourdieu justement sur la
télévision qui saura vous expliquer un
peu plus en profondeur et avec des
exemples plus détaillée et de façon
mieux présenter le la problématique de
la télévision telle qu'elle est conçue
par bon dieu je vous conseille également
le nouveau chum garde qui est un film
qui a été réalisé par serge halimi qui
est rédacteur en chef du monde
diplomatique qui est un très bon film
sur la façon dont est construit de
l'information et sur les jeux
d'influencé peut s'opérer entre entre
les différents journalistes entre les le
pouvoir économique est journaliste et le
pouvoir politique a regardé par contre
avec un certain paquet de sens critique
puisque pas mal de choses sont à mettre
en relief avec le réel et avec les
vraies contraintes
vécue par les journalistes est vécue par
les patrons de presse et par tout ce
monde médiatique qui aujourd'hui est pas
mal pressurisée quand même par à la fois
les contraintes économiques et
contraintes techniques et et tous ces
éléments par attendant la prochaine
mission le souhaite une très bonne
journée soirée ennemis tout ce que vous
voulez et on vit à la prochaine salut
tout
donc juste plus se ponctuait hockey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]